un tempo le nostre case erano
e da affreschi in queste grandi opere
monumentali che erano sulle pareti sui
soffitti sulle volte e trasferirono il
loro valore artistico alle nostre ai
nostri ambienti di lavoro ai luoghi
pubblici alla casa privata di liano
molto quest'arte è stata trasferita
oggetti più piccoli trasportabili le
tele le tele permettevano di spostare il
loro valore da un edificio un altro e
così la casa ha perso il suo valore di
oggetto che poteva portare in eterno un
valore artistico per trasferirlo agli
oggetti in essa contenuti quello che
vediamo in questa immagine lo
riconosciamo tutti è un telefono un
telefono a fili ma è anche un luogo
rappresenta rappresentava dei luoghi
della nostra casa ben definiti e nei
quali noi svolgevamo un'azione semplice
quella di telefonare ed eravamo soliti a
dire delle frasi del tipo vado a
rispondere oppure vado a telefonare
perchè andare
bisognava spostarsi per raggiungere
questo posto rappresentava un luogo di
riano molto abbiamo demandato questa
funzione object dei più piccoli più
compatti magari avanzati
tecnologicamente ma che ci hanno portato
a cambiare anche il nostro modo di
parlare oggi diciamo ho perso il
telefono non trovo il telefono quindi il
telefono che un tempo rappresentava una
posizione un luogo oggi perde anche la
sua posizione e così lo hanno fatto
anche altri oggetti della nostra casa la
libreria per esempio che prima era
difficile da collocare nell'ambiente
delle nostre abitazioni dovevamo capire
come sistemarla dentro le nostre stanze
scegliere la santa giusta perché la
libreria sarebbe stata difficile poi da
spostare in seguito
oggi abbiamo trasferito tutte queste
parole che leggiamo in dispositivi più
piccoli dai pc agli smartphone e le
librerie diventano oggetti di arredo per
alcuni i gusti alcuni stili da questo
divano da un divano come questo quello
che abbiamo tutti in casa possiamo
viaggiare possiamo spostarci nel tempo
nello spazio attraversare il pianeta
magari viaggiare in città che andremo a
visitare di riano molto oppure visitare
dei luoghi che non visiteremo mai ci
spostiamo in queste vie con
la comunicazione con il digitale senza
viverli davvero dematerializzato
continuamente alla nostra esistenza con
questa comunicazione con questo modo di
trasferirci e la nostra esistenza
diventa un continuo mutare da stati di
transizione il tempo diventa ogni tempo
il luogo diventa ogni luogo in continuo
mutamento in continuo cambiamento
e allora se dematerializzato
costantemente la nostra esistenza
qual è il vero senso dell'abitare un
luogo fisico
l'architettura tradizionale ha sempre
provato a dare un senso ai luoghi a
utilizzare i materiali più pregiati più
durevoli per poter attraversare il tempo
per essere infinito per essere infinita
la sua durata
ha provato a trasferire all aiuto al
futuro nel futuro
l'identità dei luoghi e quindi possiamo
riconoscere la città di palermo la città
di napoli perché il tessuto edilizio che
le compone le compone è ben definito e
riconoscibile ma se da un lato
l'architettura tradizionale riesce a
dare una risposta alla sede al bisogno
di identità può dare risposta alla sete
di cambiamento al mutamento un tempo
l'abitare era certo determinato e
stabile a oggi è incerto indeterminato
instabile una prova una risposta prova a
darci dall'architetto giapponese shigeru
ban che realizza con tubi di cartone
pressato un edificio di culto il paper
dom cobb e in giappone nel 1995 questa
città era stata distrutta da un evento
sismico
serviva un luogo di culto immediato per
permettere alle persone di riconoscerci
sivi nuovo in un luogo questo edificio
doveva durare tre anni e perché dopo
questo periodo sarebbe stato costruito
un edificio definitivo ebbene piacque
così tanto la gente che di anni ne duro
10 e nel 2005 fu ceduto alla comunità di
taiwan per che è stata colpita da un
evento sismico in chessa e oggi è
tuttora fruito quindi un edificio che
doveva durare tre anni
né durò dieci e tutt'oggi è utilizzato
questo vuol dire che non fa il materiale
base che compone l'edificio non non ne
determina la durata da questo divano
sono in questo divano sono state
consumate pagine e pagine di appunti
inizialmente da solo ho iniziato a fare
un viaggio per capire quale materiale
potesse rispondere a determinate
caratteristiche per poter essere
trasferito o se per dell'architettura
dopo di che ha coinvolto un gruppo di
amici colleghi fratelli che hanno
condiviso con me questo questo questa
idea utilizzare il cartone ondulato come
materiale da costruzione
ma come era possibile farlo con quel
viaggio capito che le scatole in cartone
potevano essere molto resistenti perché
perché impilate una sull'altra
permettono di fare far viaggi al
materiale che contengono in totale
sicurezza magari in vagoni frigoriferi
magari in più e più volte con un
numerosi cicli reimpiego e così da qui
parte un idea prendere ad esempio la
scatola di cartone e trasferirla a un
pannello costruttivo per l'edilizia
questo pannello e che realizzato da
scatole di cartone coassiali una scatola
dentro l'altra circondate all'esterno da
un foglio che permette di aumentare la
resistenza chiaramente come tutte le
scatole di cartone cava all'interno
quindi è possibile riempirla con
materiale sfuso riciclato e riciclabile
oppure di scarto questi pannelli quindi
possono essere tarati in base al luogo
in cui devono essere utilizzati per
esempio se dovessi di vivere un ambiente
per un periodo di tempo determinato
no sarei un folle a utilizzare il
mattone perché so che dopo quel periodo
io dovrò smantellare quel col divisorio
stessa cosa per il cartongesso potrei
utilizzarlo ma quando non mi servirà più
quel materiale è lì che fine farà me lo
sono chiesto prima il cartone ondulato
permette di arriva diciamo pronto per
essere montato e allo stesso modo per
essere smontato ma ci siamo voluti
spingere oltre nel 2018 con un workshop
di architettura abbiamo coinvolto 31
studenti del dipartimento di ingegneria
civile architettura di catania e abbiamo
coinvolto gli abbiamo fatto vestire gli
abiti da lavoro e lavorare per due mesi
alla realizzazione di un edificio pilota
il primo
ottimo abitativo con struttura portante
in cartone ondulato questi studenti
hanno realizzato il 90 per cento delle
operazioni in officina producendo dei
pannelli costruttivi e la restante parte
in opera costruendo l'edificio un
edificio talmente leggero che abbiamo
dovuto appesantirlo per evitare che
volasse via la sua leggerezza ci è
permesso di renderlo invulnerabile alle
onde sismiche leggero ma resistente
perché all'interno è riempito da fibre
di cellulosa sfusa e quindi la il
comfort ambientale è garantito un
edificio smontabile in componenti e
rimontabile in un altro luogo
l'idea quale da tritato qui sono partito
qual è stata l'idea che per certi tipi
di di difficili servisse la possibilità
di essere smontati e trasferiti per
esempio gli edifici di emergenza in caso
di calamità naturale le stesse vittime
che devono trovare casa un alloggio
immediato possono montare in
autocostruzione questo edificio e quindi
riconoscersi in esso anziché essere
proiettate spostate in case di fortuna
questo edificio è effimero transitorio
smontabile this integrabile di
sindacabile tecnologicamente in quanto i
suoi componenti possono essere smontati
e rimontati in un altro posto this
integrabile fisicamente in quanto i
singoli materiali possono essere
riciclati per produrre materia prima
seconda o disintegra bill e
biologicamente in quanto alcuni dei
materiali base sono biodegradabili
qual è il rischio che corriamo il
rischio che corriamo che l'abitare
contemporaneo
non si sa non ci sia una risposta
concreta alla abitare contemporaneo
l'abitare contemporaneo in continuo
cambiamento
un abitare contemporaneo in cui le
funzioni vengono continuamente allocate
all'interno di involucri di contenitori
funzioni che però stanno cambiando
funzioni che non dureranno per sempre ma
gli esiti di questa progettazione
rimarranno per sempre
un esempio la silicon valley da silicon
valley è un deserto che è stato
colonizzato da attività molto avanzate
tecnologicamente molto in cui il cui
sviluppo ci permette di vivere
quell'accelerazione quotidiana che di
cui parlato prima
queste funzioni non durano per sempre
durano per un periodo di tempo limitato
questi edifici però consumano sei volte
le risorse che il pianeta potrebbe
sostenere per lavoro per il loro
sostentamento e quindi stanno rubando
risorse ad altre parti del pianeta che
invece non consumano quanto dovrebbero
che sono in credito di risorse la
responsabilità del progettista e di
trovare un modo per rispondere alle
esigenze contingenti senza creare un
danno per il futuro
l'architettura di cartone permette
questo permette di da di pensare un
edificio di pensare la fine
dell'edificio al momento del progetto
progetto alla fine dell'edificio
so già dove andrà a finire senza
generare rifiuti l'articolo di cartone
permette di dare alla gente ai gusti
della gente che cambiano ei modi che
cambiano della gente e alla gente che
vuole abitare il cambiamento
un modo nuovo di abitare io in quanto
progettista o una responsabilità la
responsabilità di rispondere a queste
esigenze
il modo migliore con cui posso farlo è
pensare di rispondere oggi alle esigenze
attuali ma farlo senza creare un danno
per il futuro quindi il messaggio che
voglio lasciarvi e questo oggi c'è un
bisogno oggi c'è un'esigenza un'esigenza
attuale concreta a questa esigenza
attuale concreta si può rispondere in
modo immediato è quasi scontato con
delle soluzioni facili oppure riflettere
bene
all'esito che avrà quel nostro gesto
perché se un tempo l'architettura
permanente poteva darci un'identità una
permanenza oggi creerà solo un danno
grazie
[Applauso]